not everyone gets out of quantumania
live but how can that character possibly
come back from their shocking death
scene warning spoilers ahead phase five
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe is here
and while the Ant-Man movies have
typically served as palate cleansers in
the franchise this time around Scott
Lang is forced to battle an existential
threat when Scott's daughter Cassie
messes around with a Quantum realm the
whole ant family is sucked into a
minusculed dimension as if that wasn't
bad enough they soon discover they're
being hunted by none other than Kang the
Conqueror who wants to break out of the
quantum realm so he can carry on his
destructive timeline ending warpaths
you're an Avenger
have I killed you before Kang proves to
be the most formidable threat the
Ant-Man crew has ever gone up against
while it initially looks like Kang might
emerge Victorious and actually kill
Scott Our Heroes managed to gain the
upper hand at the very last second
during the movie's climax Scott and hope
kill Kang by pushing him into a
multiversal engine and thus the next big
bad of the MCU who's apparently so
strong he once killed a Thor variance is
unceremoniously dispatched by Ant-Man
and wasp okay stop what is that to some
kind of of
that is a very big head I am Modoc of
course death is rarely the end in the
MCU how else do you think yellowjacket
survived Ant-Man to somehow become Modoc
and given how much of a threat Kang has
been promoted as leading up to the
film's release it's fair to ask if
there's any way this version of the
character could return down the line so
what's the deal you're not the one with
the hammer that's Thor
we get confused a lot similar body types
who are you well this specific variant
of Kang certainly seems dead and gone as
evidenced by the first post-credits
scene in which three other versions of
Kang talk about the exiled one the
outright state that he's dead so it
would appear that whoever will be the
major threats of Avengers the Kang
Dynasty will be one of these other kings
or possibly all of them however Kang the
Conqueror is one of the more iconic
villains out of Marvel Comics one who
was built up as a significant threat
prior to the film's release it seems
weird Ant-Man would be able to kill him
so quickly so what if the Conqueror
isn't actually dead in the wide world of
Marvel the general rule goes that unless
you see a dead body there is always a
possibility a character made it out
alive Scott Lane pushed Kang into the
multiversal engine Kang needed for a
ship he could be dead or seen as the
ship allowed King to Traverse the
Multiverse it could be possible that
he's in another reality he might even be
somewhere so far removed from any
timeline that not even the other kings
know where he is leaving him to be dead
Kang wouldn't have his ship in this
reality so he'd be stuck there much was
in the quantum realm that doesn't mean
someone couldn't find him and help him
get back to the timeline in which he was
defeated by Ant-Man if they succeeded he
would have a major motive for wanting to
get revenge and take out Scott's world
and timeline if you think I'm
evil well
this way
until you meet bye
obviously there are other kings out
there we meet other versions of the
villain in the post-credits scene most
notably with Pharaoh Rama Tut and
immortus but it will take time to build
them up in the same way as the Conqueror
and his return in personal Vendetta
against Ant-Man would make for a great
set piece in the Kang Dynasty for now it
seems we'll just have to wait and see
foreign